The Game of Thrones Universe has no
shortage of batshit evil characters so I
thought it would be fun to take a look
at season one of House of the dragon and
rank our characters from least to most
evil now evil is a subjective term one
man's evil is another man's foot fetish
so I'll do my best to explain why
certain characters are above others keep
in mind this is a ranking up until the
end of season one of the show so it's
entirely possible characters will do
things later on that will totally shake
up the positions starting with number 10
and I think this one is going to
surprise a lot of you Eamon Targaryen in
episode 10 he accidentally killed Luke
so you can't really call it pure evil
like some of the other characters on
this list that isn't to say he didn't
want to hurt Luke for goodness sakes he
wanted him to cut out his own eye but
that's about as bad as you get with him
as a child he did claim what was
supposed to be raina's Dragon but I got
a side with aemond here you snooze you
lose Reina plus it was Reina and Bella
who started the fight which led to that
whole Fiasco in the first place for
these Reasons I'm putting aemond at
number 10. sliding further toward evil
at number 9 is Corliss Valerian he
wouldn't even be on this list if it
weren't for what he did in episode 8
where we find out he abandoned his wife
and grandchildren for six years that's
just a dick move furthermore for almost
his entire life Corliss had put his own
ambition before his family he even tried
to marry off his 12 year old daughter to
the king but there's at least one Saving
Grace here in episode 10 he repents and
tells rhaenys he's sorry for what he did
so here's hoping Corliss will make it
off this list next season sitting at
number eight is rhaenyra Targaryen her
evil Deeds aren't centered around murder
and ambition like others on this list
but lies in episode 4 she swears on her
mother's memory that nothing happened
between her and Damon in that brothel
and that her maiden Hood was still
intact these lies start Allison's
distrust of her and they fester and
build up resentment over time rhaenyra
also lie lies about the parentage of her
three sons Jace Luke and Joffrey I can't
really fault her for cheating on her
husband because that was a mutual
agreement between the two rhaenyra is
also complicit in faking her husband's
death leading Corliss and renice to
believe that their son is dead not only
that but she marries her uncle the day
after lenor's supposed death Rainier is
also a hypocrite complaining to her
father about being treated like a pawn
to be married off to some Lord in
exchange for an army when twice she
proposes various betrothals of her
children to further her own personal
position so while she may not have gone
around killing people indiscriminately
her actions certainly have set up the
events we'll come to know as the dance
of dragons at number 7 is our beloved
King viserys for the most part viserys
is a great king Otto even calls him
viserys the peaceful and at almost every
turn he tries to de-escalate tensions
rather than exacerbate them but there's
one event and I think you guys know what
I'm talking about that solidifies his
place on this list list that's the
decision to operate on his wife to save
the baby without her consent unlike Lena
who faced a similar problem on pentos
and was able to make her own choice when
it came to her body Emma had no choice
viserys made that decision for her
opting to try and save the baby which
ended up killing her he at least
recognizes that his desire for a male
son clouded his judgment he also feels
responsible for her death pushing her to
keep having children even after several
miscarriages so if it weren't for this
event I don't think I'd have him on this
list at all coming in at number six it's
our favorite foot model Alison Hightower
now for most of the series Allison has
been nothing but the proper dutiful
Queen while Ranier is out partying
Allison's having to bed her
lesion-covered husband but it's not
really until episode 6 that Allison's
resentment toward reniera builds to such
a level that her actions turn sour we
have her requesting to see renira's
third child as soon as it's born no
doubt to see if it resembles Elena Aryan
this results in raniera's painful walk
to the Queen's Chambers mere moments
after giving birth then there's the
knife attack at driftmark which leads to
Allison cunning renera a few years later
Allison tries to usurp luceris's claim
to driftmark even though she knows her
ill husband would not have wanted that
she also covers up her son's assault of
Diana paying her off with coin and
saying that if she tells anyone no one
will believe her then when the king
actually dies she tells everyone that
the king's final words were that he
wanted aegon to be king now this one
I'll let slide a bit because I do think
in her mind that's what she thought the
King was implying however she is totally
complicit in the persecution of those
who aren't loyal to King aegon and even
imprisons rhaenis at the halfway point
we have sir Kristen Cole the guy who got
so Lovestruck after blinking the
princess he basically went insane I put
him middle of the pack simply based on
how unhinged he is he murdered Joffrey
in front of everyone was prepared to
take out Luke's eye at Allison's orders
and killed Lyman beesboro even will
willing to defy the Lord commander of
the kingsguard he's also kind of all
over the place when it comes to his
moral code on the one hand telling
aemond it's important not to [ __ ] talk
women and on the other calling Hima
Kristen you gotta cool it down all right
now we're getting into some real bad
eggs at number four is aegon Targaryen
while he might have started small with
little pranks to his brother here and
there and some harmless jerking outside
a window I mean who hasn't done that
from time to time things escalate
quickly aegon is known to frequent
brothels where he has many bastard
children these children are forced to
fight in underground Rings where aegon
is set to frequent however it's also
unknown if he really knows these kids
are his or not regardless aegon is an
assaulter and seems to show No Remorse
for it and who knows how many times he's
done this to other women he also treats
his sister wife Helena like utter [ __ ]
now I did consider switching Kristen and
aegon's position here but it was the kid
fight club that did it in for me at
number three is Damon Targaryen out of
all the characters this guy has probably
done the most bad [ __ ] or at least the
most bad [ __ ] that we've seen however
the degree to which you could say it's
evil is what stopped me from putting him
higher on the list the guy basically
terrorized the citizens of King's
Landing when he was head of the city
watch called his brother's dead child
the air for a day and lied about
marrying messaria and her with child so
he could steal a dragon egg he brought
his underage niece rhaenyra to a brothel
and almost had sex with her if that
wasn't bad enough he killed his first
wife Rhea Royce and would later work
with renira to fake lenor's death so
they could get married he kills vamund
in front of everyone although that was
probably going to happen regardless he
threatens Stefan and Lauren to prove
their loyalty and seems more concerned
about the war than his wife's Health
when she's giving birth not to mention
choking the queen so the guy has a
pretty big rap sheet but there's just
something about the next two that put
them higher on the list at number 2 the
man with a foot fetish Laura strong in
the book this guy is so manipulative
even the historians aren't sure what
side he was truly ever on and he started
his menu regulation of Allison when she
was young first telling her of the Moon
tea that was delivered to rhaenyra in
the middle of the night this is what
sparked Allison to question Kristen Cole
about Rainier's Behavior leading to her
finding out about their Affair You could
argue that the whole Dance of the
Dragons never would have happened if
Loris hadn't intervened here Loris also
had his own father and brother killed he
had murderers from the dungeon have
their tongues chopped out presumably so
that it could never tell who sent them
and sent to assassinate his family via
arson so he could become Lord of
harrenhal of course he told the queen
that he did it for her Lars also oversaw
the Roundup of those disloyal to aegon
and personally tracked down lord Caswell
and had him strung up in the courtyard
because you're never quite sure what
site he's playing it makes him extra
dangerous when confronted about the
amount of time he'd been spending with
Alison Lars tells Otto that his time
with her could benefit him too but
perhaps his most unforgivable Act is his
love for feat he uses his power over
Allison to pleasure himself in exchange
for info information the fact he has so
much control over the second most
powerful person in the realm should be
very concerning and my pick for the most
evil character in season 1 goes to Otto
Hightower the Mad lad did it Decades of
scheming have helped him undermine the
king's true wish to have rhaenyra on the
throne and part of this included him
pimping out his own daughter like a pawn
at every turn Otto used his position as
hand of the king to put down rhaenyra
and prop up aegon and while he did
things like try to use Surplus Eris from
driftmark and plotted behind the king
and queen's back it really isn't until
he takes over that we see just how
ruthless he is upon learning of the
King's death he calls for rhaenyra and
her family to be killed he rounds up
hundreds of Castle workers City
Guardsmen and Lords to be taken into the
dungeon in the book many of these people
are killed he just goes full mask off
and this Tyrant will do anything to put
his grandson on the throne at grandson
he doesn't even really care for let's
not forget that viserys even implied
that years ago Go Auto may have been
involved in the death of his father so
he could become hand of the king to Joe
Harris we never really know if that's
true or not so the reason I put Otto in
the number one spot is the scope of his
dastardly Deeds while demon and lorus
have killed Otto is just on another
level and is cool and calm demeanor
hides a ruthless Tyrant who will do
anything to get his grandson on the
throne so that's my ranking agree
disagree let me know what you think in
the comments below and if you haven't
seen my season 1 breakdown definitely
give that video a look thanks for
watching for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
wonderful if you really pay me enough
we'll massage your feet in any of these
sauces also
foreign